danielle up tiene que resolver el
siguiente problema una partícula se
mueve en línea recta con una velocidad
de dtm de la raíz cuadrada de 31 metros
por segundo donde t es el tiempo en
segundos en t igualados la distancia de
la partícula al punto de inicio era de 8
metros en dirección positiva cuál es la
posición de la particularmente igual a 7
segundos ok y me preguntan qué expresión
debe usar daniela para resolver el
problema y tengo cuatro incisos así que
pagos el vídeo inténtalo por tu cuenta
bien ahora trabajemos los juntos
queremos saber la posición la posición
de la particular ente igual a siete
segundos y sabemos cuál es la posición
ente igual a dos segundos por lo tanto
para encontrar la posición de la
partícula ente igual a siete segundos
tenemos que sumar la posición
igual a 2 segundos más el cambio en la
posición desde t igual a 2 segundos
hasta que igual a 7 segundos
la posición entre igual a 2 más el
cambio en la posición desde t igualados
hasta t igual a 7 y ahora hay otra
palabra para todo esto a esto también se
le conoce como el desplazamiento al
cambio en la posición desde t igualados
hasta t igual a 7 se le conoce con el
nombre de desplazamiento que en este
caso buscamos el desplazamiento desde t
igualados hasta t igual a 7 y sabemos
cómo trabajar con el desplazamiento en
este caso este va a ser igual a la
integral desde t igualados hasta t igual
a 7 de la función velocidad
entonces me va a quedar la integral de b
dt
esto será el desplazamiento desde t
igualados hasta t igual a 7 de hecho si
nos pidieran el cambio en la posición
desde t igualados hasta t igual a 7
bueno pues sería esta expresión de aquí
ahora bien nos piden encontrar la
posición de la particular ente igual a 7
segundos por lo tanto tenemos que tomar
en cuenta la posición ente igual a dos
segundos que ya la sabemos eran de ocho
metros es justo lo que me dicen por acá
recuerdas por lo tanto a este
desplazamiento
le voy a sumar la posición ente igual a
dos que era de ocho metros así que esta
es la expresión que voy a buscar entre
mis incisos y si observas es justo el
inciso ver el inciso b me da exactamente
esa expresión el inciso am es decir b de
7 lo que nos da es la velocidad en 7
segundos o dicho otra manera la tasa de
cambios del desplazamiento
igual a 7 segundos así que no en
definitiva no es lo que buscamos lo voy
a cancelar en la opción cm
entendemos bueno nuestra posición entre
igual a dos segundos y después tenemos
nuestro cambio en la posición desde t
igual a cero hasta t igual a 7 por lo
que esta tampoco es mi opción correcta
la voy a cancelar y el inciso tm bueno
tengo mi posición entre igualados hasta
aquí vamos bien más de prima de 7 pero
la derivada de la velocidad es la
aceleración así que tengo la aceleración
entre igual a 7 lo cual en definitiva no
es lo que buscamos por lo tanto voy a
cancelar también este inciso y ya
podemos decir que la opción correcta es
el inciso b hasta la próxima